là bien entendu c'est l'inévitable
réunion de des étudiants en comité
d'action une réunion à laquelle a
participé pierre dejean en mai 1968 cet
habitant de montigny le bretonneux à 19
ans il est étudiant en génie électrique
à l'iut de ville d'avray
les affrontements entre étudiants et
policiers le 10 mai 1968 ont déclenché
la mobilisation dans cet établissement
le gouvernement à cette époque là d'un
le le 10 mai a fait un acte d'autorité
qui n'était pas justifié et on a fait le
tour des classes qui était déjà donc
entamé puis on a dit écoutez il ya quand
même eu des événements importants
cette nuit une répression assez dur faut
au moins qu'on fasse quelque chose on
fait on fait une manifestation à bild à
brac la mobilisation ne s'arrête pas là
des professeurs de l'iut se joignent au
mouvement
les cours sont arrêtés la grève est
lancé malgré l'opposition de certains
étudiants
on a dit bon écoute et on fait pas grève
on suspend les gours ce qui est
exactement la même chose mais pour
d'autres qu'il voulait pas s'engager pas
ça permet effectivement da tout arrêter
des photos des journaux ou des
caricatures pierre dejean conserve de
nombreux souvenirs des mobilisations
sociales notamment la manifestation du
13 mai 1968 à paris un des slogans comme
bug lié à ce camp bin salman station ses
10 ans ça suffit
10 ans ça suffit la société est
effectivement très bloqués on parlait
fallait que ça change quoi fallait que
ça change
le changement c'était aussi la
principale revendication des ouvriers de
l'usiné renault à billancourt
jean pierre wolf avait 30 ans à l'époque
il vivait à versailles et travailler sur
l'outillage il produisait des machines
pour fabriquer des voitures sur l'île
seguin
la mobilisation a commencé le 16 mai à
boulogne on a décidé de d'arrêter le
travail et que les étudiants qui ont eu
beau me dire comment plfr c'est la
couleur a dit au 11e boisgelin vous êtes
chez vous on est chez nous des
revendications distincte des étudiants
comme
amélioration des conditions de travail
la hausse des salaires ou encore plus de
protection sociale l'augmentation
générale des salaires pour toutes les
catégories
c'est albert 7 le secrétaire du syndicat
jean pierre wolf se souvient du
mouvement à l'intérieur de l'usiné
tout comme le travail sur les machines
la mobilisation s'est faite avec son
binôme
on a mis nos machines en état de de
propreté de conservation aussi roulé
depuis ce qu'on allait permettre le
boulot tout de suite
donc on les a nettoyés comme il fallait
il soit et puis on les a évidemment une
on les a et 1 et puis on a commencé à
récupérer pendant 30 août 33 34 jours
nous rappellent big men ta bio on a
dormi la boire une nuit sur deux le 17
juin 1968 la reprise du travail est
votée
jean pierre wolf et ses confrères ont
obtenu notamment une hausse de leurs
salaires